along the strip homelessness has some
visitors concerned about their safety
that's right jeremy j ford went to find
out what can be done to clean up certain
areas
[Music]
homelessness appears to be plaguing the
strip but as some people fear their
safety there's homeless that feel they
just need a little help not everyone
wants to be homeless out here like i'm
not a bad person i'm an honest person
i'm a hard working person and not
i just want to be treated as such that's
all musician chamber king moved to las
vegas from kentucky with his girlfriend
but as the relationship failed so did
his living situation i can't stay in one
spot because i'm impeding pedestrian
crossings and scaring people like
tourist hayley glascock lots of like
screaming and like hey can you pay for
this can you do that which like i am 100
for people in need that should be helped
but not in that manner
anybody who's ranting and raving and
somebody sees that they're going to be a
little bit put back by it obviously it
could scare some people but according to
social media influencer stephen campbell
anyone who comes across as a homeless
individual should remember the homeless
are people like anybody else a lot of
them have severe problems that we don't
know about i hope that everyone that
needs help seeks help in the right ways
and not in harassment or violence or
ways that are not acceptable and
shouldn't be jeremy j ford live local
now
jeremy thank you for that well jeremy
did reach out to metro police they did
sent him they did send him a statement
that says in part homelessness is a
community problem and it is the duty of
patrols and enforced statues and
ordinances now metro police also created
the homeless outreach team with the goal
to address the problem and bring
resources to those in need